Hello Freak bitches to be more considerate or more kind.
It's about calling people out on doing something wrong and stopping them.
Do you think the intent matters more than the word hundred percent?
Cause I feel like we saw that a lot with,
um,
there's a,
there's two big youtubers that were in the news,
uh,
or one was in the news.
There was a cutie pie.
Yeah,
let's talk about that because I saw his response video and I kinda got sickened.
Oh really?
By what's happening to him.
Oh,
by what's happening,
I think you're saying.
Yeah,
no was words.
Well,
he was,
he was crazy.
It was crazy.
The whole thing is insane.
They're making it out like he's a Nazi and he's not at all.
No.
He had made some,
some videos where he had told people to not be Nazis.
Not until like two.
Don't you know,
what was his exact words?
I know.
I don't want them to miss [inaudible].
They,
it originally started with this whole fiber video that he did.
Um,
and then Fiverr.
Yeah.
So it's like a website where you can get people to do thing for things.
Originally for $5 now for more money.
And so he went through the site.
It all started from this one video that got him attention.
He went to Fiverr and tried to get people to do ridiculous,
outrageous things.
Okay.
Um,
get a guy dressed as Jesus to say something weird.
He got these,
uh,
the main thing that blew up where these two guys,
they're like,
they're in like a jungle setting of some sort.
They dance,
they laugh,
they'll hold up a sign,
they'll say something.
And so he was like,
it's going to be hilarious because they're not going to do it right.
They're going to be like,
thank you.
But no.
Um,
but they actually made a video where the guys were laughing and dancing,
held up a sign that said a death to all Jews and,
and then said to subscribe to a youtube channel.
Right.
The whole of,
uh,
of like someone else asked them to say death to all Jews.
So he,
he wrote in as like a cause in the same video.
He gets all these people that are like,
I'm not going to do the stupid ridiculous thing that you said,
but then they actually did it.
The,
the big reason I feel like they did it is they didn't understand what the words
they were writing in the words that were saying,
oh,
they're from another country.
What country were they from?
I don't know.
I'd have to,
I'd have to double check.
Okay.
So they just essentially wrote down the symbols.
They didn't really know how to even say the word.
And so it is,
there it is.
Oh yeah.
And the laughing.
Yeah.
And so I think this might be from his explanation video,
but in the first one,
he's like,
why the fuck did they do it?
How do I,
can I even include this?
Um,
and so then that sent that got that,
got a little traction and then people started going through his other videos and
they were like,
he's,
he's dressed up.
Uh,
he's watching Hitler.
And this one taken completely out of context of him saying that the Youtube
Heroes Program,
which was a program where people can,
uh,
highlight videos are not highlight them but mark them down for deletion because
they're offensive.
Right?
And so people were like,
oh,
that censorship that's you're talking about like obviously hyperbole.
It's like those are Nazis.
So he made that joke in that relation.
And then there was one,
if I want to say if it was on the verge or wired,
but then they go even further there.
Like he used Leslie Jones Picture,
um,
on Harambie taken completely out of context because he was using,
uh,
there's this Microsoft Ai Bot like this chat Bot and you'd say,
let me see Heran as Jesus.
And uh,
either the AI was messed up or people had manipulated it where it was putting
Leslie Jones his face on it.
And he was horrified by it.
And that was the whole joke.
But they were saying that he,
he was doing it.
So this is clear.
Like he,
you saw him use the software and you saw the error.
You try and use the bot today,
a picture won't come up because now they are aware that that's what was
happening,
right?
And so they took all these things and it was this like this crusade of,
look guys,
we're looking at this bad guy.
He's the biggest guy on youtube.
He's the bad guy.
We're going to take them down.
So much taken out of context.
Some things are not defensible where I can't,
I can't say it in the sense of like you say that words don't have power based on
intent.
And I think there's a,
there's a lot of truth in that.
Not saying words don't have power baseline tent.
I'm saying that words should just convey intent.
Right.
And there are times where a word,
there's times where like you see a friend and you go,
what's up bitch?
And you know you haven't and you're both laughing and you're being silly.
And then there's times where you call,
some of them want a bitch,
right?
Because you think they're being mean.
Yeah.
I mean those two words exactly the same,
but one conveys a completely different intent.
Right?
But out of this,
it was,
it was very obvious that they were trying to do this take down thing and it blew
up entirely in their face I think
because I don't think most people are aware,
I mean there was a Wall Street Journal article on it,
right,
which was where it,
where it got really weird because three people worked on this and they comb
through hundreds of hours.
Yeah.
I mean,
yes.
And they found like instances of him holding his arm out like this and they used
that picture.
Like there's a,
I mean that's,
that's weird.
It's very weird.
And then,
and then once all that came out that they were like,
well,
here's the thing about the context.
He's just like Donald Trump.
And it was,
it was an immediate jump to,
he's using the same tactics tactics has Donald Trump,
but it's,
it's,
it was just insane.
No,
he's very reasonable.
He did a video response video about it and the way he handled it was very
reasonable.
And he explained what he was doing and what's going on.
And you know,
he's doing hundreds of hours of him playing video games and talking and being
silly.
And if you comb through those and take these things again out of context and try
to make it look like he's a Nazi,
that's a hit piece and 100% and it's deceptive.
It's not indicative of his overall,
it's hard to call it a body of work,
but let's call it a body of work,
right?
His overall body of performance that he's,
that's online,
whatever you want to call it,
right?
His talking,
it's not who he is.
So that for them to call him a Nazi and say that Pooty Pie has,
you know,
seven videos where he's done something about Nazis,
like people when they're doing these long forms,
spit ball,
improvisation videos like that and you're interacting with people,
you're going to say all kinds of shit that in the moment
is legitimate.
Right?
But if you chop it up and edit it and splice them all together and then make a
five minute montage of him saying Nazi,
like he's obsessed with Nazis and with what kind of sucked from it was a lot of
people think that,
oh,
they're there articles about the downfall of Pewdie Pie.
I think he's gone up half a million,
if not more than a million subscribers since all of this happened.
Right.
So he's gotten all this new support.
He's a temporary phase for a,
for free speech,
free speech and uh,
persecution for mainstream media.
Didn't,
you'd lose some,
some get a matter for him though.
He so,
I mean it sucks more for the people that we're working on that project.
What was the project?
So it was scare Cutie Pie.
Season two.
It was a youtube red series.
Um,
so they were,
I think there were about to go into production,
um,
and,
and so then that got canceled.
So Youtube didn't want to fund that.
And I said it,
he said it.
He understands why they would have to separate because then it becomes a story
of Youtube and beauty or youtube and Disney support an antisemite.
Right?
He's not an antisense.
Right.
So why would they back away?
I think because they were scared that the Wall Street Journal was like,
did you see all of this?
We're going to write this article out of the Wall Street Journal at that slip
through.
That seems to me very irresponsible.
Any of them are standing by it though.
Many people,
yes,
100% and the many are touting it as this victory because he lost a Google
preferred ads on youtube,
which I will say,
I don't know how he was still seeing as family friendly cause I'm not family
friendly on my show his past two years,
at the very least,
not family friendly.
Uh,
and then uh,
dropped by maker.
Uh,
he doesn't,
he doesn't need his,
uh,
his MCN has his company around him and the youtube red series is nothing.
He's still going to make millions of dollars.
He's grown it.
It's a good thing.
I feel like it now,
if you,
if you have mainstream media,
try and take a swing at you.
It's some of the best promotion in the world.
Okay.
But why did they take a swing at him and why is anyone saying that they took
down a bad guy?
I think that it's,
it's a big thing of them trying to label and it's once,
once again,
it's the problem with a lot of media is there,
they're overextending,
right?
They all of a sudden start talking about this narrative about outright and the
rise of white supremacy again in this country.
And then they look at this big guy and they're like,
we can use him as an example.
We can be the heroes that expose this,
that do the takedown piece.
Um,
and they're not and they're not.
And they're like so driven for that,
that they then just,
they go,
oh well maybe that doesn't add up there.
It's an argument.
But we have the power,
we have the size of the audience were good and it just blew up in their face.
So they were thinking they could get away with it.
Even though it wasn't kosher.
I believe so too.
What is the response so far?
Do you know?
Have you read anything about it?
But as far as like fans or Wall Street Journal posts,
post chick digging their heels in and then a lot of people started trying to
find as always a dirge stuff.
Turn it on like the,
the authors in the past one was like a,
a joke from 2015 because and,
and while,
pardon me would go,
well that's petty.
If the argument is that context doesn't matter,
then fine then then look at these guys,
what they said a year ago.
Look at what they are saying.
Now look,
the writers who have the art of the article,
like I think Ben,
Ben Fritz was one of the art with the writer is where you made a,
I can't,
I never knew Jews were so good at frying joke,
uh,
from way back.
And then he made another joke about a,
it was like a back and forth with someone where he said,
you know,
these racial jokes are so stupid.
And then someone said,
Eh,
you know,
they hit everyone.
And he said,
well,
at least the black jokes are funny.
Those ones,
those ones are funny.
Um,
and so people were like,
well,
if,
if context doesn't matter,
are you a scumbag?
And,
and then people just dismissed it as are a lot of mainstream people dismissed it
as like,
oh,
that's,
that's not the same thing.
How could anyone say context doesn't matter.
That's insane.
That is an insane thing to say.
Is that literally what they said,
they context it does not matter.
What was it?
It was one of the,
one of the people I'm going to get the,
the problem is so many people have written about it.
There was one article that was promoted and it said,
uh,
all these are articles,
or all these people defending Felix with.
But context,
that's,
that's a bullshit argument and that's insane.
If you think that that's an insane,
so everything exists in a,
in a highly edited bubble.
Dope.
So that's ruined everyone's career.
If you're talking about a mathematician discussing algorithms,
yes.
Context doesn't really mean that much because he's talking about numbers,
but we're not talking about numbers.
Talking about words.
Yeah.
We're talking about the way people express themselves and we're talking about
someone who's generally considered to be humorous.
I mean,
Pooty Pie,
a lot of his stuff is playful and humorous.
So if your humerus and you're playing around and you say something that might
be,
I don't even want to use the appropriate,
it might be the thing for him to say in that moment to try to be entertaining.
Right.
That does not mean he's a Nazi and two,
to label him like that is incredibly irresponsible and it's,
it's really bad.
I mean,
I'm not a lawyer,
but I would sue the fuck out of him if I was him.
I would sue the fuck out of them for sure.
Yeah.
Because what they're doing is misrepresenting who he is as a human being and
even if it's beneficial in the long run,
it's super dangerous to set that precedent.
Well,
especially something in this,
in this climate where you say,
this is what he supports and it 100% isn't.
How do you know someone doesn't just see those articles,
it doesn't see as defense and tries to kill the guy.
But why would the Wall Street Journal do something like this?
Wait to jump back to,
to what you were saying about mainstream.
Do they have to go back?
Matt Pooty Pie guy and Europe places I get scared when everyone talks about
stuff in generalities.
Right?
When I talk about,
and I'm guilty of it too,
when I talk about like all mainstream media,
it's not everyone,
you know.
Um,
but there are,
I,
I stopped doing interviews with mainstream outlets several years ago because
they made everything about,
like I would talk about all the really cool ventures that we're going into,
how,
how our space is changing things up.
And it would always be turned into.
Um,
one comment that maybe was somewhat critical of let's say like a,
a studio and all become about that.
Or if all become about like the money and,
and I was like,
you just fucking manipulating what I'm saying.
I don't want to deal with it.
Yeah.
And so the point is become,
uh,
when,
when the Wall Street Journal knocks on Felix his door after they didn't
apparently approach him,
uh,
for the original story.
And they're like,
hey,
we want to give you a platform to tell your story.
It's like,
fuck you.
Is that what they're doing now?
Uh,
yeah.
They,
after the story broke and there were all these people that came to his defense,
they came to him.
Now I'm not going to,
that's what I think that's what a journalist should do.
Right.
Talk to the fucking main source,
but not be after the fact.
Journalists.
Well,
so I think from what Felix,
uh,
wrote,
it was the Wall Street Journal.
They left their cards and that's how he knew it was 100% of them.
Um,
but why does someone,
I mean,
what I mean is different journalists from the Wall Street Journal,
not the same age as me to hit.
I don't know if it was the same ones.
He didn't.
He didn't say,
Hey,
we're super sorry.
We called you a Nazi in front of millions of people and we were totally lying.
Yeah,
but the argument all of a sudden is it why?
Why should he do an interview with the Wall Street Journal?
Maybe because they have a different audience,
but he has his own larger platform where he controls the narrative.
He's not going to be selectively,
but he's not speaking to the people that the Wall Street Journal risperidone him
in front of it,
but I would assume that there are also covering their ass by going to him and
reaching out and giving him a platform.
They can say,
well,
we gave him a chance to respond in the facts remain.
He did say those things and they are valid I think.
I think if he was confident enough,
you should probably do what I've seen Milo Yiannopoulos do in the past where he
had someone film at the same time,
so if they did misrepresent him in some manner
matter,
it doesn't matter because they've already done it.
They've already misrepresented him in the article.
If they,
if he has someone film his response to that,
I don't know.
I mean,
just if he did something with them,
right.
If they did film something,
I understood the film,
the entire thing,
just so you can show,
but I'm saying it doesn't matter because they've already done the damage,
the damaging thing.
Like how many people who read the first thing or even going to read the second
thing,
right?
It might even be 30%.
Well,
that's 70% people.
And how many people just read the Wall Street Journal and maybe a local paper
and our online and aren't hearing all these responses and they go,
oh,
you know,
he's catch their son.
Oh,
I'm watching Pooty pie.
you watching that Nazi?
That guy's a Nazi.
No,
he's not dead.
You hate everything I like
and now that kid's doing meth for the rest of his life.
I don't know.
No,
I,
uh,
I think that it is sad,
right?
That's,
that's a huge problem with,
with a lot of the fake news or just news that's false is the,
the crazy salacious shit.
If you then look at the correction half the time that gets like 20 times the
shares,
you know why?
Cause it's fucking insane.
It's like,
did you see this?
Did you see this thing?
And it's something that I've been critical of people I like in the industry,
a critical level out of the mainstream guys.
I don't like it.
And it sucks because there's not,
there's not a clear answer.
Do you delete the false thing and then it looks like you're hiding that
information.
Um,
do you do what?
You should definitely delete the false thing.
But,
so that's my argument.
But then there's,
there's an argument that you,
you leave it up because you show that you were wrong.
If it's on Twitter,
you quote tweet it,
but that's still,
that's still doesn't fix it because,
um,
as much as we talk about and separation
that tweet,
that promotion of a thing is separate from everything else in the world.
Tweets are problematic anyway because it's 140 characters.
And it's very difficult to adequately explain some subjects and 140 characters.
But if you put out some information that's not true,
like this Pooty pie thing,
right?
You absolutely should print a retraction and you absolutely,
if you have,
it's still up on your website.
The first thing you should say is this is all taken out of context and it's
incorrect and it's not.
It does not represent who this guy is and you should absolutely not have those
writers do that again.
Right?
I mean whether you fire them or whether you assignment,
who knows what they were asked to do.
This is another part of the problem.
Was this an independent thing that they decided to pursue on their own?
Did someone ask them to do it?
Was there someone who decided that this guy was a Nazi?
Cause that maybe they tuned in at the very moment he was doing something right
and they're like [inaudible] and some people obviously are very,
very sensitive to that kind of stuff.
So I think that's why it's important,
especially on a,
an editorial team of some sorts.
I have people with with mixed opinions because it's very easy to all of a sudden
get railroaded behind an idea of just like,
yeah,
look at these,
look at these seven specific things.
We're not going to say that it's out of context,
but look at this information.
We got this guy we got where they got this guy dead to rights,
but it's,
it's all flimsy.
Well,
again,
context,
right?
As soon as you,
that is part of the problem with doing something like you do and it's certainly
part of the problem with a co a podcast is if you're talking for three hours and
you take these little snippets of those three hours out of context,
it paints a completely distorted perception of who the person is,
but that that's also a problem with language in general.
It really is a problem with,
and it's certainly a problem with words and that's one of the problems with
these quote magic words like that you're not supposed to say anymore.
Whatever those words are,
you know,
the,
you,
you give the weight gives so much weight to these words that just taken alone
on,
on their own.
They can get you in trouble.
Just saying,
uttering the phrase as if it was a magic.
Abracadabra.
I think it get you in trouble.
I think it's important that we stopped trying to a got it rhymes and it's not on
purpose.
We have to stop just blindly hating and we try and educate.
Right.
I think that don't blindly hate educate.
It's an afterschool specials.
Philly d.
Oh God,
that sounds like straight up.
Something from the 90s you're on a skateboard,
you pull up.
Don't hate educate.
Yeah,
but I mean.